This is a painting called "Palisades."
It shows what once used to live
up along the Hudson River,
north of New York City.
I actually built it to help fund
a new park in Guatemala.
If you and I were to take a walk
through that site right now,
we would see some of these
plants and animals,
but a lot of them would be missing.
And to be honest, we wouldn't notice.
Gradual change is really hard
to notice over time.
My artistic practice is an investigation
into humanity's relationship with nature,
both what we have,
but also what we've lost.
A painting like this one
called "Understory"
begins with a rubric and a database,
not with drawings.
The rubric is the rule of the painting.
For this one it is these are new species,
and the database is built out
of a sampling of plants
and animals that fit that rubric.
It took me about four months of research,
probably two or three months of drawing
and another six months of painting
to complete "Understory."
Most of my complicated, complex paintings
take roughly a year on average.
These works are my form of activism.
When I want to research a bird,
I go to a natural history museum,
and this is exactly what I see.
It is a box of specimens,
or also called study skins.
This happens to be a bird
called paradise parrots.
They used to live in Australia.
They are now extinct.
Specimens have an amazing value.
They are ...
They are two things.
One, they are a genetic library of traits.
And at the same time,
they carry within their feathers
and their skin and their scales
a lot of environmental
data that we can use.
When I check out the specimen,
I do drawings of it,
I do color studies of it,
I do measurements,
I take my own measurements
and photographs.
And I do all this work because I really
want to be able to depict them accurately,
and I want them to be remembered correctly
and as if they are living,
not just a dried skin.
This painting is called "Canopy,"
and it is an exploration of species
that have just been discovered.
Every single living thing you see in it,
every little moss, every insect,
each and every thing is new
to Western science.
I say new to Western science
because it has certainly not just evolved,
and it is not new to the people
who live with it.
They probably have their own name for it.
But it is new to Western science.
That newness can carry some risk.
There are collectors who love
to have a new species.
I call this painting "Trade"
because it is about black market
trade and wildlife.
Each of these things
is taken out of nature
and sold somewhere,
either legally or not legally.
Both novelty and rarity
have this awful way
of driving prices straight up.
There are plenty of regulations
about the sale of wildlife.
There's lots legal protections in place,
but they just are inefficient
because there is such a drive
for wildlife purchase.
Imagine all of the wild places
there are in the world,
the million acres,
all of the markets in the world,
all of the dark web.
There are just never enough boots
on the ground to save wildlife.
It's a big drain on all of nature.
Humanity has a way of taking
what we want and what we need,
but we have never really learned
or gotten good at putting it back.
We're like kids or toddlers, maybe.
This painting called "Back"
is about our hope
that nature is resilient.
Everything in this painting
falls into one of two categories:
it was either thought extinct
and then re-found by pure luck
or very hard work,
or it was on the very brink of extinction
and was hauled back with some
sometimes pretty extensive interventions.
So on the upper right,
there's a Mauritius kestrel.
It's a white bird.
It went down to actually
four individual birds.
It took an amazing amount of effort
on the part of a handful of people really
to get it to breed again.
These were not so lucky.
Everything in this painting is extinct.
Every grass, every egg
represents a bird that's extinct.
I don't mean that they're extinct
just here or there.
They're really gone from the world.
You may be able to tell that I studied
the Dutch still life masters.
That was very much on purpose.
And I did it because some
of their paintings
are between 400 and 500 years old now.
Why are they still here?
They're really beautiful.
That's a great kind of insurance.
And they also were made very, very well.
Just the materialism is really strong.
So I have borrowed
a bunch of their techniques,
most of their materials.
And I marry that with modern science
so that I can share
with future generations
some of our understanding
of what's happening
to our biodiversity right now.
Like what's struggling,
what's thriving, what's doomed.
The paintings are kind of like
an environmental snapshot,
a picture in time.
Or maybe better,
like a message in a bottle.
With luck, these paintings
can talk to the future.
This is a detail from "Gone."
On your left, there's a bird
that I showed you as a specimen,
the paradise parrot from Australia, gone.
In the middle is a passenger
pigeon, which is extinct,
despite the fact that there were
millions upon millions of them.
They used to darken the skies
of this part of America, the Midwest.
The yellow-headed bird on the right
is a Carolina parakeet
that used to raucously fill the skies
of the southeast of the US.
This was the first painting
I did of extinct species.
So it's kind of "Gone 1."
But I really, really don't want to have
to paint "Gone" 2, 3, 4 or 5.
When I started college, I thought we were
in the middle of an environmental crisis,
and we were.
Audubon thought we were
in the middle of a crisis,
an environmental crisis, in the 1840s.
I don't think either he or I could
have possibly imagined
the amount of cumulative
destruction of nature
we would see within our lifetime,
within each of our lifetimes.
The depth of our disruption of nature
is so extensive now
and so global,
that we are, of course,
affecting the systems
that govern the water,
the weather, the soil,
the oceans, the climate, all of them.
These are the very systems
that we rely on for our survival
and that nature relies on
for its survival.
I think of my paintings
as alarm clocks in a way.
They are reminders of what's at stake.
The only real problem is we keep
pushing the snooze button.
I plan to keep documenting, in paint,
biodiversity that's at risk,
making a record of it
and advocating for biodiversity as I can.
But what's probably more important
is what is the next message
that gets carried through
these paintings into the future?
It's humanity collectively
that will decide that message.
I've thought it could be:
well, too bad, these are the ghosts,
these are what we lost.
But it would be much better
if that message was,
this was the moment
we started to take action
where we really tried
to save life on this planet,
including our own.
Thank you.
(Applause)